huh a little bit better oh hey I'm here
to talk about important changes to
notifications in Android Oreo up until
now there hasn't been a unified way for
users to have fine-grained control over
the notifications for a single app if
you have different types of
notifications there might be some of the
user cares a lot about and others that
they are less than thrilled to receive
unless you've made custom preferences
for your user the default user choice if
they don't want some notifications as to
I just want to turn off all
notifications for this app or do I just
deal having the user shut off all
notifications is no good for you and
it's no good for the user if they miss
an important update shoot where's my
demo phone oh also introduces
notification badges and other snazzy
updates but first let's look at those
new notification channels notification
channels give five grade notification
control with the consistent settings UI
to users Here I am on my odof ice I've
just got a new notification about a
friend follow me neat I can long press
and I see that I have the option to turn
off the followers Channel or take a look
at all of the channels notification
channels which are also called
notification categories of the UI our
collections of associated notifications
every notification and Oh needs a
channel or it won't even show up for my
new social local app I have two channels
one for all of the notifications about
follower updates and another for direct
messages you'll want to separate out
your different types of notifications
into different channels you can further
organize notification channels into
channel groups channel groups let you
group notification channels together in
the UI for example you can have a
channel group for your work account
notifications and for your personal
account notifications to set up a
channel you simply create a notification
channel object with a unique string to
identify it you can then add the default
settings for that channel and submit the
channel if you want to add a channel
group you can make the group and then
add it to your channel submitting a
channel is much like giving it as a gift
to the user once you've submitted the
channels the user now owns them and has
full control over their notification
settings as a developer you can no
longer modify the settings of that
channel you can see what settings the
user has chosen and
can make suggestions but they have the
ultimate control making channels is
important because when you make a
notification you pass in the channel ID
in fact you must pass in the ID or your
notification won't show up on Oda vices
and you'll get an error in addition to
notification channels Android Oreo
introduces notification badges also
known as dots the default behavior for
launchers that support badges is this
when there are outstanding notifications
for an app I see this little circle on
my launcher icon I could then log press
to see a count of all of the out setting
notifications and swipe through them
this new feature comes for free for
devices running out if you need more
control over when to show badges to your
user or if you control the number of
outstanding notifications there are
options for you so check out the docs
finally
OOW offers a few other cool notable
features you can set the background
color for your foreground notifications
using the new set colorize method you
should only use this for ongoing
notifications that are of the utmost
importance for the user to notice at a
glance like a notification I'm actively
using for directions Sebo devices now
support lockscreen ordering using the
category priority and associated people
for the notification and the messaging
style style now displays more content in
its collapsed form there's also a add
historic message method that lets you
show a little bit more context for the
conversation we have a sample code lab
and documentation to get you started so
take a look
[Music]